it never ceases to amaze me
we all love ourselves more than other
people
but care more about their opinion
than our own
you have power over your mind not
outside events
realize this
and you will find strength
when you arise in the morning
think of what a privilege it is to be
alive
to think
to enjoy
to love
the happiness of your life
depends upon the quality of your
thoughts
everything we hear
is an opinion
not a fact
everything we see
is a perspective
not the truth
humans have come into being for the sake
of each other
so either teach them
or learn to bear them
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
be one
if you are distressed by anything
external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your estimate of it
and this
you have the power to revoke at any
moment
the best revenge
is to be unlike him who performed the
injury
it is not death that a man should fear
but he should fear never beginning to
live
[Music]
our life
is what our thoughts make it
whenever you are about to find fault
with someone
ask yourself the following question
what fault of mine most nearly resembles
the one
i am about to criticize
if it is not right do not do it
if it is not true
do not say it
very little is needed to make a happy
life
it is all within yourself
in your way of thinking
reject your sense of injury and the
injury itself disappears
the first rule
is to keep an untroubled spirit
the second is to look things in the face
and know them for what they are
how much more grievous are the
consequences of anger
than the causes of it
do not act as if you were going to live
10 000 years
death hangs over you
while you live
while it is in your power
be good
here is a rule to remember in future
when anything tempts you to feel bitter
not
this is misfortune but
to bear this worthily
is good fortune
how much time he gains who does not look
to see what his neighbor says or does or
thinks
but only at what he does himself
to make it just
and holy
do every act of your life
as though it were the very last act of
your life
what we do now
echoes in eternity
the impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
receive without conceit
release without struggle
your days are numbered
use them to throw open the windows of
your soul
to the sun
if you do not
the sun will soon set
and you with it
it is in your power to withdraw yourself
whenever you desire
perfect tranquility within
consists in the good ordering of the
mind
the realm of your own
if man despises me
that is his problem
my only concern is not doing or saying
anything deserving of contempt
a person's worth
is measured by the worth
of what he values
whoever does wrong
wrongs himself
whoever does injustice
does it to himself
making himself
evil
the memory of everything is very soon
overwhelmed in time
nowhere
can man find a quieter or more
untroubled retreat
than in his own soul
confine yourself
to the present
because a thing seems difficult for you
do not think it impossible
for anyone to accomplish
death smiles at us all
all we can do
is smile back
choose not to be harmed
and you won't feel harmed
don't feel harmed
and you haven't been
full account of what excellencies you
possess
and in gratitude remember how you would
hanker after them
if you had them not
a man must stand erect
not be kept erect by others
we live only now
everything else either past or is
unknown
[Music]
no man can escape his destiny
the next inquiry being
how he may best live the time that he
has to live
you